Steve: Good morning or good afternoon, I don't know.
Laura: Good afternoon.
Steve: I have the great pleasure
to be able to speak with a Spanish polyglot.
Who lives in Germany,
who teaches languages through
the internet and whose name is Laura.
Native of Barcelona.
Good afternoon Laura.
Laura: Good afternoon Steve.
The honor is mine, in fact.
I'm delighted to speak with you
and have the chance to meet you.
I love your videos,
so it's amazing to get to know you.
Thank you so much.
Steve: Too much... How do you say?
Polite.
How do you say "polite" in spanish?
Laura: Ah ehmm...yes.
Too much...
Oh, see?
That´s what happens to me.
As a polyglot, we are a bit
bilingual and forget the words.
Steve: Kind?
Well, let's go with kind.
Laura: Yes, well educated.
Steve: Well educated?
But hey, kind.
Laura: It's the truth Steve,
because I watch your videos
And man, as a polyglot, it's normal,
isn't it?
You inspire us all.
Well, I think I speak
for other people as well.
Because yes, you're an inspiration.
And I'm looking forward to talking to you.
Steve: Well, thanks.
If you viewers enjoy my videos,
you can click the bell
to subscribe to updates.
One thing that came to my mind is that
though it's not my strongest language,
I can still use Spanish.
However, there are always words,
that you forget, that you don't know,
that, at the time you want to use them,
are not searchable.
For example "polite".
How do you say polite?
There are many examples.
Now I am mixing
Spanish and Portuguese, mostly.
I think that many times,
people who study languages
feel the frustration
of not being able to look up the word
at the time they want to use it.
And this is of no importance,
just the fact that it doesn't feel so good.
Which seems worse.
It's a matter of pride.
But it has no significance.
It's not that important.
Laura: Exactly, absolutely.
That happens to me a lot,
because look, I live in Germany.
And since I have learned so many languages,
and I've been living in Germany for 10 years;
and my daily life is in German.
My mother tongues
are Catalan and Spanish,
but I even forget my own mother tongues.
Sometimes I'm talking to my parents
and I say "How did you say that?"
I therefore constantly say
that this is common.
For example in my channel,
which is called "Couch polyglot",
what I am trying to convey is
that making mistakes is normal.
That it is human, and that learning
languages has to be for fun.
That has to be the goal.
And do not become obsessed.
"I misspoke this word" or
"How do you pronounce that?"
Well, you can rephrase it.
You create the sentence
in a different way and that's it.
Steve: Exactly.
One thing, though...
In the case of the Ukrainian...
because in Ukraine, people speak
half usually in Russian,
and the other half usually in Ukrainian.
But there is also a language
called "Súrzhik" in Ukraine.
Which is a mix.
Because people
are bound to get confused.
They will use Russian words
in Ukrainian, and vice versa.
This phenomenon is
often seen in Catalonia.
Because the two languages
have a lot of each other.
Can it happen that a person
think he/she speaks Spanish
but uses Catalan words?
Or the other way around, speaking
Catalan to use Spanish words.
Laura: Yes, it happens a lot.
In fact even,
when I speak in Catalan,
there are some "castellanismos",
which are called,
which are very much incorporated.
For example, instead of
say "ve" we say "buenu".
We "Catalanize" it a bit.
We don't say "bueno", we say "buenu".
Things like that, right?
And that´s part of everyday life.
I try to avoid that in my videos,
but in real life people talk like that.
Languages are a little bit
mingled in the street.
Or occasionally you might be narrating
an anecdote in Catalan
when you accidentally slip in
a hilarious Spanish term.
That might occur, for instance.
And also the other way around.
Those who mistakenly believe
a word to be Spanish
when in fact it has Catalan roots.
I believe that this is inevitable,
because the languages are in contact.
Steve: Yes, it is inevitable.
It's like this.
That languages will eventually evolve.
In English, for example, there are
now few people using, for example,
"Whom" "To whom?"
"Are you speaking?" "To whom?"
I use it because I am old
and I still use "whom".
Now there are people who
say "I would have went".
Which is awful.
It makes my ears hurt.
But it is possible that in 50 years
it will be normal, won't it?
Because languages are always
changing and evolving.
I hope that the Catalan
language survives.
Laura: Oh, I hope so too.
Honestly.
We´ll see.
Steve: In your channel, which I will
leave a link in the description,
and it's called "Couch polyglot", right?
Laura: Yes.
Steve: What is it all about?
What is the goal?
What do you want to achieve
with this platform?
Laura: Well look, that was
really spontaneous.
It was early in the pandemic.
And I am a very outgoing
person,
and I was climbing the walls from stress
and not knowing what was going to happen.
And I said "Oh, I need a new hobby.
I'm going to create a YouTube channel.
And it went like this.
And then I decided to create
videos in different languages.
For example, I create videos
teaching Catalan, Spanish and German.
Which are like my strongest tongues.
Then I also create videos
showing how I learn Italian,
how i learn swedish,
by doing experiments,
doing interviews
with other polyglots.
So it's a bit of a mixed bag.
It is not just a language,
it is thus a potpourri.
Steve: Yes, yes.
Very goog.
And after this interview,
we are going to talk on your channel
in different languages,
so we can show this topic.
I think the fact of being able
to speak many languages
5, 4, 6, 7...
is within everyone's reach.
People do not need talent,
they need interest.
And the brain is very flexible.
Maybe not all at once,
but one language after the other
you could learn 4, 5, 6, languages.
And speak them quite well.
When I say I speak 20 languages,
I don't mean I speak 20 languages well.
No.
I speak five to six languages fluently.
There are 5 others that I speak,
but not as well.
And some with great difficulty.
But I always have a great time
learning and exploring
languages, cultures and all of that.
And everyone can do that.
If you have the interest
and the motivation.
Laura: Yes, I have
seen it for real.
Because one of my friends
struggled with English at school.
It is also true that in school, english
is taught in a very theoretical way.
Perhaps because it does not awaken
the interest of the students and so on.
Well, maybe it has changed.
But then, later on,
she fell in love with a French boy
and learned French very quickly.
So there she had a very strong
motivation,
and then at that moment
she realized
Ah, I'm capable of learning languages."
But sometimes motivation
is a little lacking.
And there are many people
who have the belief of
"Since I couldn't learn English
as a teenager, or as a child,
is that I no longer have the talent
or I won't be able to.
And we need to completely
alter that mindset.
It's what you say, I think that
everyone can learn languages.
So do I, too.
Steve: I believe that the fact
that in schools they teach
grammar rules so people may think
that they need memory,
or that they need an ability
to understand those rules.
But in fact, if you don't have enough
experience with this language,
all explanations are worthless.
That's why I always say,
that they must allow people to
study the language they are interested in.
For example, in Canada,
all English speakers,
have to learn French.
If someone does not want to
learn French,
is not going to learn French in order to
to have a sense of patriotism.
If someone wants to
learn Spanish or Chinese,
let them learn
the language they like.
And then they can learn
French, whenever they want.
So I believe that the way
of teaching languages in schools,
has done a lot of damage.
People who are interested,
are interested in the same way.
Laura: Anyway, yes.
But I, for example, the first language
I learned, let's say consciously,
was English.
However, looking back,
I see that I learned it through music,
which I found interesting
and enjoyed it.
With Harry Potter books,
that I didn't want to wait for
for the translation to come out.
Things like that.
So those grammar lessons in school
weren't the cause.
And then you think about it and you say,
"Wow, so many years studying in
school and people do not speak English".
Many people in Spain do not speak English.
And it's a bit sad, isn't it?
Because so many hours dedicated,
and if it were done
in a slightly different way
then perhaps people would talk more.
Steve: Tell me, I have the impression,
that the Portuguese speak
English better than the Spanish.
Do you agree?
Laura: Yes, I have
that impression too.
Well, that was my impression
when I went to Portugal on a trip.
I realized that of course,
they speak Portuguese, Spanish and English.
Of course, also in more touristic areas.
But I think that in
Spanish in general,
people think that because it is
a language with so many speakers,
you just simply "don´t need" English.
If you look at smaller countries,
for example in Sweden,
people speak English really well.
In Germany, too, in general.
Steve: The Portugal and Spain case,
in my opinion, is highly intriguing.
It is the fact that well,
Spain is bigger than Portugal.
There are more speakers of
Spanish than Portuguese.
Although in Brazil there are
about 200,000,000.
Additionally, it seems to me
that there are more sounds, right?
In Portuguese than in Spanish.
The vowels.
There is more vowel variety
in Portuguese than in Spanish.
But also the fact
that in Portugal,
television programs are in their
original version.
Which is not the case in Spain.
Laura: Oh, that helps.
Steve: And in Sweden or in Holland,
all TV programs are in English,
French, German, etc.
But not in Spain. They are dubbed.
I think they are dubbed.
Laura: Oh, yes.
That's correct.
And then I also have friends who
sometimes want to practice English
and put on TV,
for example "Friends",
but they played it with
Spanish subtitles.
And I'm thinking "No, put it on
with English subtitles".
Because the brain, I think,
always chooses the easiest option.
Which, in that case, is reading in Spanish.
So that's what I say.
What you were saying about vowels,
which is interesting
because there are 8 in Catalan,
for example.
Then that also...
And well, the fact of growing up
bilingual even though they are
similar languages, también ayuda.
I believe.
Steve: I believe that in
the case of Catalans,
who´ve learned Catalan and Spanish
since childhood,
this should increase their brain's
adaptability.
Initially.
So perhaps the Catalans
speak other languages better
than someone from Madrid.
Laura: Yes, but in this case,
I believe it is even better,
for instance, if someone speaks
Basque and Spanish.
Due to languages differences.
However, a large number of Catalans
also struggle with their English.
That is, like everywhere else.
Steve: Tell me about
grammatical complications.
For example in Spanish or Catalan,
many people have difficulty
with verbs
With conjugations.
Laura: Conjugation.
Steve: But in German,
there is this problem
of what is called in English
"Declensions".
Subjunctives that change.
Laura: Awful.
Steve: How were you able to overcome
this obstacle by learning German?
Laura: Well, yes and no.
Ja und nein
Actually I´m telling you,
I speak German quite well,
I would say I have a C1 level.
But I don't always do it perfectly.
Sometimes I forget,
Is it da, die, das?
However, there are guidelines,
and as you mentioned,
The brain recalls information
if there is a lot of input.
There are certain structures
that are automated.
And it is the same as
happens with da, die, das.
Sometimes you have to pay attention,
cause I knew a guy who decided
he wasn't going to learn that.
He said "I will always say da."
Always da.
And I said okay, fine.
You will be understood.
But I think that's a bad strategy.
Nor should we go to the other
extreme and say
"I want to say everything perfect".
Well, it's going to be hard.
Over a certain age,
that perfection will come.
I think it is impossible,
or almost impossible.
In my opinion.
Steve: Yes, I agree with you.
Most people want to
communicate clearly.
They want to speak according to usage.
Just as native speakers use the language.
That´s the goal.
I want to sound more German.
But if I'm going to be thinking
all the time if it's die, das, da,
I won't be able to speak.
So you need to have balance.
Yes, I want to speak better.
But I know that by studying the...
How do you say?
"the tables".
Laura: Declinations.
Steve: Declinations.
Laura: Or the gender of words.
Steve: Yes, studying and
trying to learn and memorize.
It does not work.
So it's a combination
in which, from time to time
you are going to pay attention
to those endings.
However, I'm going to read and
listen during the 80% of the time.
I occasionally plan to review
the rules I've already forgotten.
But I can't think about it
while I'm speaking Spanish.
I'll errs, I know that.
Err
Errs is on Portuguese.
Laura: It´s normal.
Steve: If I'm going to think about
whether it's this or that,
I won't be able to talk.
So yes, it's a balance.
I cannot ignore it,
"I'm using der.
That doesn't work either.
Laura: That was certainly
going to the limit.
But yes, I do believe
in a middle ground.
A balance. Do not go crazy.
I realize it too, as I started
learning Swedish a year ago.
I have noticed that my German
has gotten a little bit worse.
But hey, I'll take it, you know?
I prefer to speak more languages
a little worse,
because I might as well say:
"I´m focusing only on German,
I'm going to do a C2".
But that doesn't make me
personally fulfilled.
Everyone has their own
goals and that is not mine.
So I'm happy, satisfied with
my level and that's it.
Steve: I completely agree with you.
Understanding is the most
important thing of all
The most important factor for me
will be how many languages
I can comprehend and understand
Sometimes I make more mistakes
than other times when I speak.
Because now you are studying Swedish,
having a little bit more mistakes in German.
If you focus on German,
you will speak with fewer
mistakes in German but more in Swedish.
And what is the importance
of all that?
Laura: None.
Steve: Exactly, none.
Is Swedish easier than German?
Laura: Well, I´m not sure.
Mmmm, yes.
I think it has helped me a lot
speak German quite well.
And then I'll start podcasting
and so on.
I mean, that motivated me a lot.
What I don't like is that phase
of not understanding anything.
I like to have
interesting resources.
I don't want to study with a
"Hi, my name is x".
It bores me to death.
So I spent about
a month with Duolingo,
a bit with a book I had.
And then I put on easy podcasts
of A1 or so,
and now I'm listening to some A2-B1
podcasts and I understand it all.
Then talk, of course...
it's a little more difficult for me.
Because it's all input
and then the output comes out
but sometimes it works out
well and sometimes not so well.
But that's it.
Steve: Don't tell me you
didn't use LingQ for Swedish.
Laura: Yes, I have used it.
Steve: The mini
stories to start with.
I always use mini stories
to start every language.
Laura: Yes, I'm actually thinking
of doing an experiment with LingQ.
Perhaps to learn a new language.
Steve: Okay, very well.
Laura: It´s just that I want
to invest time in it.
That's a bit of the problem.
The podcasts work very well for me
because, for example,
I put on a podcast and start
preparing my breakfast.
I'm in the car,
I put on a podcast.
That fits my life quite well.
Steve: Let's finish.
It seems to me that
there are people who think
hat they need a talent
to learn languages.
In the end, we just need enthusiasm.
And what it feels to talk with you,
is enthusiasm.
Laura: Oh, thank you.
Steve: With enthusiasm we can
all learn any language,
or any number of languages
we want.
Laura: Yes, I believe
it's really...
Sorry.
I think it is
enthusiasm and dedication.
What fascinates me about the book,
I don't know if you know the book
"Atomic Habits"
It is a book that I loved
and in fact,
after reading that book
I started with my channel,
I started learning Italian, etc.
Because with little changes,
with small steps
you reach big changes.
And that's what
I do with the Swede.
10 minutes a day minimum,
is my daily routine.
So I have that rule
and that helps me a lot.
Steve: Yes.
Exactly.
Well now we are going to do
an interview on your channel,
where we will speak
in several languages.
Laura: Yes, awesome.
Thanks Steve.
Steve: Thank you so much.
Great pleasure.
Laura: Bye.
Steve: Bye.